foreign
corpses Halloween and The Devil's
Rejects brings you the greatest love
story ever told oh I I don't like the
sound of that
brain of the Super Genius transplanted
into the body of a perfect physical
special
I want a man that makes my blood run
cold a man that every time he enters my
Crypt it's like a state through my dead
black heart I could whip you up a humpty
down in the lamb oh no remember what
happened last time he was batted
I'm gonna go
okay I'm looking for a vision a queen
true love what exactly do you want is
Herman Munster in there
uh-huh I knew the moment I laid eyes on
you that you were special I understand
if you don't feel the same I'm just a
regular gal living a boring normal life
if there's one thing I know is that the
rest of the world melted away
as soon as you approve in my life it
seems Miss Lily is truly in love oh come
on you know and I know that we gotta get
rid of that Bozo Herman Munster
foreign
[Music]
greetings from Transylvania
[Music]
strange way of saying hello oh my guess
we're gonna have to get used to it
[Music]